all right so hi everyone my name is
Stanley and this is my colleague Peter
so we're gonna take you guys through
this tutorial today I hope it's gonna be
very very useful so just a quick word of
warning we can actually do a lot of
hands-on exercises so we want you guys
to follow through and and you go through
the exercises with us so please put up
your hand if you're like stuck somewhere
we have two of our colleagues here it's
gonna help you that's Donald and that's
way you so they're gonna try and if you
guys run behind just to come and help
you if you don't follow or is something
that's just stuck with so please put up
your hand and don't be scared to ask
questions we do want you to follow
through and all the exercises so let's
go to the first slide so a quick
disclaimer here so we're but we're all
four actually work for for Barclays and
so all the views expressed here is not
necessarily the views of Barclays it's
all of our own content even though we're
using their representation format
alright so quick a quick introduction so
that's our links to to LinkedIn so
Stanley funded America and in bitter
wolf so I'm just a bit of my experience
I've been in data scientists for about
ten years now with Barclays developing
statistical models on the retail side we
predominantly actually used SAS for Amol
developments and I actually have most of
my experience was with SAS and it was a
decision wire management a few years ago
to change over to Python and fully just
use Python so today we're only just
using Python which is good we have a bit
of legacy SAS code left but we basically
just everything is transferred to Python
which is a big good journey for us so I
have about two years experience with
Python and then Peter here is in my left
he's actually the opposite he's very
experienced with Python he's part of the
QA team as well so QA is quantitative
analytics in Barkley's and he's been
actually very interesting instrumental
in that process of us switching over to
Python so and then just quickly the
slides all of these slides you don't
have to take pictures you can just find
them on the github link and also for
code and setup we will go through that
in the presentation but we'll have this
link on by data in YC 2019 to get up
it's big
every slide as well you'll see we've put
it there so we want you just to follow
through those there's like a readme on
how to get set up we'll go through that
now so let's jump to the next slide so
just the abstract I think all of you
would have read this coming to the port
tutorial so a quick summary is normally
just think of it when you start writing
new code there's a few things that we
actually put right at the end of the
priority list normally those are
reproducibility how you structure your
code and also just the runtime
performance of your code and what that
does is it actually has an impact on a
successful implementation of your code
or for the continued use of your code
and also the the maintenance cost in
terms of time and money when you when
you do that so what we're trying to do
in this tutorial is we're going to
highlight some steps that we think will
improve your code and improve its self
life and also actually hopefully will
lead to others wanting to take your code
replicate and build on top of that so
that's what we're trying to do with this
tutorial today so what you'll learn is
you'll see or do you will learn how to
structure your code into composable
reusable blocks and then you also will
we'll jump into the first thing would be
insight using insight and to do that to
replace boilerplate code for data
loading and then we'll also start
looking at it tasting and also like code
quality and they will look specifically
at by taste if we have some time and
towards the end of the presentation
we'll look at hypotheses and in also
pilant and then we'll look at
performance by using profilers and joint
and then once we've identified
bottlenecks in your code we'd want to
try and show you what what types of
tools like Nimba you could use to to
make it faster so this - in terms of
show of hands who actually has used
things like who's used intake before
like just show of hands alright and in
terms of pi test does anyone use pi
taste before ok good and then what about
hypotheses for testing ok one and in
Pyland have you used any of that before
for code quality all right and then just
any type of like profilers a line
profiler per father or writing last one
new Nimba is anyone used number
all right good so I think you're gonna
learn a lot based on that so let's let's
jump into the next slide quickly so just
in terms of who this tutorial is for so
it would be four people and that's why I
actually asked for showing off your
hands would be and this is once you've
started getting into Python what you
want to take the next step in trying to
improve your your skill set and if you
predominantly use Jupiter notebooks and
you want to actually move and step step
away from rather actually use this in
conjunction with other tools we're going
to teach you
and also if you're similar to me you've
moved over from a certain code by you've
used to using and you came to Python now
and some of the best practices you can
use and we want to try and highlight
today this might not be is certainly a
good tutorial for you if you're very
very experienced with writing modular
and testable code and also if you're
very very experienced in automated
testing and code optimization so in
terms of what we can occur today there's
about seven basics that are main steps
you're going to look at firstly on the
right you'll see here is a typical
modeling notebook so please again as
part of my disclaimer now don't use this
modeling notebook for your modeling
purposes it's really really basic and
actually shows you how not to do things
so what we're gonna start with that and
in bold on top of that and see how we
can improve it so and then we'll just
quickly jump into setup first then we'll
go to reproducibility data sourcing
tasting and then we'll look at the card
quality in performance and after each of
these sections what we'll do is we'll do
a summary just to make sure we we cement
ideas we trying to convey all right
so quickly these are pictures that we
had you're all barclays approved
pictures so what we're gonna try and do
is we're gonna show you instead of we
want to take show you the bad which is
like represented by the cupcakes here
and then we want to show you instead of
doing the bad let's let's do the better
which would be like using the fruit and
the vegetables there so what we'll do
and every type in those seven steps I
mentioned as we'll do a brief
explanation I'll do that
and then we'll do a quick demo and they
will ask you to do and follow through
with hands-on exercises and you'll see
with this we're actually gonna repeat
things like almost four or five times
and the reason for that is we found that
that's our
people actually learning you want to
grease a mint idea first let's plant the
seed and then we're gonna actually go
through step by step get you some
experience and we're gonna do a summary
to recap at the end so I think just if
you go to the next slide you'll see
we'll do a sample solution once you've
had some time with the exercises
yourself and then we'll do a summary in
recap to make sure we highlight the key
points all right so an otoscope today
would be these points here
version control continuous integration
peer review documentation and automated
data validation these things are really
really important we just want to tell
you just bring attention to that they
are very important and with the tools
we're gonna highlight today you have to
use them all in conjunction to actually
get a really good code base so and is
what we've done is we've left some links
at the bottom of each slide which is
some good reading these two actually
these two links we actually read through
and about the premise for our discussion
today a lot of that came out of DC links
so I would encourage you to go and read
a bit more about this if you in your own
time okay so let's let's jump to this
data set up so actually you'd better do
you want me to hand over here or do we
yeah so Peter will take you quickly
through this set up and as I mentioned
sorry would be if you if you're
struggling with the set up just put up
your hand and our two colleagues they
would also help you so hi everyone
thanks for coming um so hopefully the
set up is actually easy if you've done
it already on your computer you're all
set I hope if you're not if you have not
done the set up yet you can use the
binder link that's either on the slides
or also on the under get up home page
that will take you right into a browser
interface where you can interact with
our notebooks if you do prefer to run
this on your computer it will take you 5
to 10 minutes to set it up using the
instructions again on github so either
people who are having issues setting
things up if you do just raise your hand
donal tour where you will come by we can
at this point just switch to the
notebook
you have to scan
so you have two options if you're on our
github you can either press press this
link or you can do these steps of the
local insolation
if you have not done I would recommend
you go with the binder link which will
open in a new window it will take a
minute but it should drop you right into
tutorial page that looks like this so
can we just get a quick check on or what
do people are set up if you could raise
your hand if you're all set and you can
see something like this in front of you
either locally or github looks good
so I can see a lot of hands but not
everyone has right to hurt your hand so
we're going to continue with the
tutorial but if you do get stuck please
let us know and someone will stop by and
help you out it's important so that
everyone is set up otherwise this
tutorial will not be very useful for you
all right let's bring up the slides
again so you'll see there's a few
exercises we mainly going to use Jupiter
notebooks throughout the tutorial but a
few just a few notes on tooling so
you'll see that there are a few py files
in the exercises and we're actually
gonna edit those and save them and then
run them again so if you just look at
the instructions here so if you see any
dot py file Peter will take you through
that but you'll click on that file and
then you'll you'll edit it and just save
it with some of the policy exercises so
it's here and step one into just shows
you how to do that and the second thing
we'll do is we'll also use the terminal
so and this is actually optional so
we'll you can go into Jupiter notebooks
a new terminal and we'll use that for
some of the tasting exercises it's just
actually the the benefit of this you're
gonna run it in the terminal you'll get
some nice colors that shows red you
failed your taste or green you've not
failed you taste
otherwise you can also use some special
Jupiter magics
you can use the percentage or the
exclamation mark which bear will also
show you how to to use that later on
okay so let's go to the next slide so
our first point would be reproducibility
so what what what do you think of if you
think of reproducibility so a quick
definition for this would be a
reproducible data science project is one
that
other people to actually go and recreate
what you've done and embolden upon that
so that's what I would say is a good
definition so you allow others to use
your career it or modify it and why
would we actually want to focus on
reproducibility while the few key points
if you highlighted here is you know I
think both of them in your jobs as well
be assignments similar that the only
things start off as a one-off analysis
and then once you find that this is
actually good analysis you want to
repeat this so if when that happens you
don't want to go back and try Andrea
understand your code from from scratch
again you actually want to be able to
use that code and put it on either in
production later on or be able to run it
very quickly the second point also if in
a modeling environment where you do like
data science and you both predictive
models you would want to recalibrate
these models maintain them and also
monitor them and in sport of this as
well you don't want to go and if you
have to recalibrate say quarterly or you
have to go and do some maintenance you
don't want to go and figure out oh where
did I save this data why did I do this
thing here why do I have this huge huge
function that has like several hundred
inputs so you would actually ask
yourself these questions and those
questions would just go away if you if
you write reproducible code and then the
next two points would be their projects
actually to promote knowledge sharing so
if you have a reproducible project just
think about if I send you a notebook and
it's very all over the place it's not
really well constructed I don't have any
comments in there I don't have any sales
written would you actually spend the
time to try and read through this and
understand this thing I don't think that
answer would be yes it would be you
would actually didn't just move that
away and try and write something out of
your of your own so it promotes me
knowledge sharing if you have something
is very very easily understandable and
to follow as well so that's the third
point and then the last one would be you
might want to move your projects to
production so when you think of
production is normally three things that
pop up the first one is is your code
doesn't have tastes well written tastes
that's the first question the thicket
second one would be is your code isn't
actually optimized for performance so
that'll be a second question and in the
third thing would be
do you have code qualities so there's
some some standards that you have to
follow code quality is your code of a
high enough quality that it can move to
production and we're actually going to
touch on all three of these points in
today's tutorial all right so let's
let's move to the next line all right so
we now first exercise we're going to
open a notebook in the exercises folder
and called zero one reproducibility you
can get there by clicking in the
tutorial in the exercises folder I'm
gonna do that just in a second we're
going to use some slightly unusual
commands in that notebook to check what
packages will Python packages which
we've installed what version of Python
were running I'm going to try digging a
little bit deeper to also look what
version of the operating system we're
running on why that's important
packages change computer systems change
things of all things that work today may
not work in a month's time things that
work on your computer may not work on
other people's computers things that
work in development may not work in
production for for various reasons so
these are things that are actually very
important to keep in mind and have some
control over if you want yesterday to
the great Netflix talk on
reproducibility you would have learned
actually much more on that which is
going to focus on one particular aspect
or reproducibility here which is the the
various version versions of packages so
I'm going to switch quickly into an
notebook
so if you're set up you can just follow
into the exercises folder and open the
first one
let me make that bigger and so everyone
should at this point be following with
us you can have this in front of you and
you can run these commands with me so
everyone's using empandas right but if
you do that you can also check a special
attribute of pandas called underscore
underscore version lot of libraries have
that not all but if you want to know
what version of pandas you're actually
using right now on your computer or in
your environment this will give you the
answer and if you follow the
instructions or you running on binder
you should actually see exactly the same
as we do if you're seeing a different
number you have a different version of
pandas you makes you struggle with the
tutorial there's special commands in
python that you can use to list all
packages I'm gonna use one here pip
freeze the exclamation mark here if
you're not used to that is a way in
Jupiter to execute system commands we
alluded earlier that you can do the same
in the terminal if you prefer using
terminal and you're comfortable doing
that you can switch to using terminal
but for the purposes of the tutorial I
think we're going to stay in Jupiter all
the time P freeze lists all the packages
why is this important you may want to
save this as a by-product metadata of
your analysis so that you can later
recreate the same environment or at
least know what versions you've used
similarly if you're using Condor for
packaging depending on how you installed
it condor list will give you a similar
similar output you can dig deeper you
can actually wonder what version of
python you're running in and that also
changes so that would be in the SIS
model here we're on Python 3 6 it's
actually relatively old there is Python
3 7 now even python 3 3 8 just came out
very recently and with every released or
breaking changes there there are
differences in behavior differences in
numerical results you may get so all of
this is important to understand finally
the operating system that were running
on can also be inspected from the Python
platform module and so now everyone will
probably get something slightly
different
are you running I told me at a Windows
Linux Mac OS if you're running in binder
it's gonna be some virtual Linux Linux
platform there's some more useful things
from the platform module like what
processor you running what architecture
32-bit 64-bit etc and if you kind of
losing losing track and thinking this
does not matter there's an article you
can read that just recently came out it
was episode of Python bites podcast that
talks about it were the very tiny
difference in the platform actually
caused a big difference in total
scientific papers because of slightly
different behavior of a certain function
on one version of an operating system
versus another and this got accumulated
because it wasn't a shared utility that
got copied over into many projects and
used in hundreds of scientific papers
and so details can k matter before we
move on I would just check in with you
if everyone is following the tutorials
if anyone's having any troubles running
things this was basically a warm-up
nothing really difficult or
groundbreaking here but just a check in
with everyone if you're not set up by
now not able to run these cells let us
know someone will stop by and help out
and with that I'll hand it over
all right looks like Ron's up and
running so what I'll do next is just
jump into our our next exercise or just
give an interested to that first and
that will be no actually let me just
quickly finish with with the review like
I promised so so why does
reproducibility matter a few things
we've mentioned now is or we haven't
mentioned explicitly but it is important
is it's for collaboration purposes and
you want people to reuse what you watch
what you've created and also for my
instance purposes like I mentioned if
you have a model you have to recalibrate
that or you have to maintain that you
want that to be reproducible ways of
making your project more reproducible is
actually something that we've just done
here you you have to explicitly make
sure that people know what the
dependencies are and also the
requirements and this can be done in one
of two ways you can do it with the
requirements that txt file in the root
directory which we've put on our github
repository and also with a getting
started guide a part a getting started
guide in your readme file will also help
and in three other points here which
we're actually going to touch on some of
them here in the presentation but the
one it's all scrubbed like you mentioned
is version control but we just wanna
bring your attention back to that again
it's very very important you do version
control so just took up to backup your
codebase firstly it else it helps with
collaboration like I mentioned it
stopped and also it helps with tracking
any changes to your code base so then
the third point here was also actually I
should you should to make sure your code
is trust is trustworthy and people trust
it much more if there are written tests
well written tests you can run to your
code base and then the last thing is
actually that that would this forces you
almost to make your code reproducible if
you work with a big team of people
multiple people on multiple environments
this actually forces you to to start
getting your project in a reproducible
manner so that's the fourth point and
then again here we have some very very
useful links that you can go and read
about more about reproducibility I want
to actually bring your attention just to
the third bullet point which is talk
python episode two to seven I would
actually encourage you to go and listen
to that one Sunday afternoon if you have
some time it's very very good stuff
listen to an
have some good links to papers there as
well so let's go to the next point so
now we're getting to data sourcing as
promised
so um a few things so you know that
there's quite a bit of time and effort
that goes into finding defining data and
also loading data when we start working
on projects so as a data scientist or as
someone that wants to use data there's
actually just three basic things you
want to know you want to know what type
of data is available you want to know
what format it's available in and how do
I get my hands on this data so we can
start doing an analysis and also one
thing it's very very frustrating with
dealing with data is the amounts of
boilerplate code you'll need to use to
try and get your hands on the data so
that brings us to this library or this
package called intake and what intake
does is it provides a very very simple
but very useful split between the data
users so the data scientists and also
the maintainer of data the data source
catalogs which would be their data
engineers or your your your team that
provides data so what this does it
provides the the Freedom and the
flexibility to this title engineer teams
to go and decide whether they want to
store your data in what format do they
want to store it and also how do they
what packages they want you to use to
get your hands on the data all you
actually want interested in is getting
your hands on a data frame or something
like that and they know that and this
this clear split actually helps helps
with setting those guidelines then what
intake also does is they have like a
consistent approach to organizing their
data and also the the commands you have
to use to get your hands on the dates
are you don't want to every time you use
a different data format you don't want
to go and learn a whole new set of
commands and tastes and things like that
if you just learn like a intake and you
know this is how I get my own data it's
much easier and also saves time and
that's actually done through their data
cataloging system and this provides you
with descriptions of the dates are some
of the arguments you can pass to load
the data and also some arbitrary but
very useful metadata that you can use
with these catalogs and we're going to
look at a few catalogs as part of the
exercises and then also you it also
tells you which plugins you're gonna use
to to load the data so just in terms of
the plugins how do we define a plugin
and this actually comes from the intake
documentation they actually say that the
business of
plug-in is to actually move from a
certain data format into a container
that you're used to working with so like
a Python list or a panda's data frame or
a numpy array or something like that so
that's that's what a plug-in does just
get you to that container of the data
and there's some built-in plugins for
insight and those are like CSV numpy
text files like what like we mention
here on the slides and then we also have
from some extendable z' here
bark a spark is-3 and many more which we
created a link for if you guys wanted to
go and jump into that so um I think
we'll now go into our first actual
exercise quickly now hand over to Peter
to do that thank you so before we jump
to the exercise I wanted to kind of
illustrate that problem a little bit
more in using this sample notebook that
we mentioned at the beginning as the
thing that you should not do put it up
on the screen and we look at this
notebook it illustrates a typical
workflow someone might do in model
development we'll go through it step by
step
but we've began with reproducibility we
talked about how important it is to
actually know in what versions we're
importing all these packages and now
we're at the data loading part and what
you might see in a lot of code actually
I should say the data we're using here
is generated dummy dataset it doesn't
have any actual value so again please
don't do any real modeling with it but
it's based on a California housing data
set that that comes from a really great
book hands-on machine learning that if
you want to know how to do things
properly in that space you should you
should definitely follow not learn from
us but in terms of the actual
implementation what you often see is
it's gonna be called something like this
so you know uncommon on Michaels
computer then there's gonna be a pass on
Michaels computer both will have its own
version which will not work then there's
gonna be something that no longer works
and then you're gonna have a command at
least a dead loss data and if they're
actually still there you lucky often you
will find that the file is gone and you
don't even know where to find it and
that's over right at that point
everything else is useless here the data
is there I
so you should be able to read it and
look at the data frame which has a bunch
of columns about housing prices in
California we're going to use that as a
toy model but the point I'm trying to
illustrate that this is this is bad the
parsing actually is also having some
issues and so we're going to try doing
something better we're gonna use intake
to standardize the Y data sets are
loaded and share that with with others
I'm just gonna keep this view for a
second we're gonna open the notebook to
we're going to look at what at intake
catalog might look like we're going to
incrementally improve it until it
describes the data set correctly
I'm gonna try using it and then there's
some optional exercises that you might
do if you're running ahead I'll bring
this slide up again or you can follow on
your own using the PDF in on github so
again from the from the home page going
to exercises I'm going to open up
notebook two and so please follow with
me I'm gonna import Parnassus before now
we're also going to import intake and so
what intake does it lets its place the
role of a data provider in a data user
so as someone who's bringing in and to
your company or for analysis a new data
set you have to go through a lot of pain
you have to find out what the data are
how to parse them how to understand them
and so intake is not going to take that
away you still have to go through the
pain but what it helps with is that you
know the only person that has to do that
because you can describe this process in
a concise way and then you can share it
with others so that other people can
really benefit from what you've done and
simple oh the data without having to
repeat all these mundane and error-prone
parsing steps so an intake catalog is a
text file in any AMA format what we'll
look at we'll look at it just in a
second this is one that would describe
the data set again I'm using a special
Jupiter command to list a file if you
wanted to click on it you're not
educated we'll do in a second you just
navigate to it in your Jupiter browser
it has a mandatory header with version
we can ignore the
for a second and then it has a list of
data sources here we only have one entry
in that space called housing we gave it
a description we say it's a CSV file and
we say where it is that's pretty much
all the file currently says but as such
this file could be shared as a way of
standardizing the instructions intake
can read that file and the command for
that is open catalog loaded into Python
and tell me things about it it can tell
me now what sources I have in that
catalog obviously there's just one the
one that we defined I can access that
source and see some of these properties
so the things that we we saw above the
CSV format the description some of the
parameters you can access it through a
dot or through square brackets if you
prefer but most importantly there's a
read method so once I've decided this
define this and loaded it I can press
read and I get a data frame bag so if
someone had done this catalog definition
for me as a user
I don't write anything special I don't
even know where the data needs to be all
I do is I press read and I get a data
frame which is kind of the ideal case
you're going to be at so the exercises
here will now go and edit that catalog
to resolve a bunch of issues that we
still need to take care of in terms of
the parsing so one issue if you note if
you look at the data there's a median
house value that actually isn't in the
right format it has a comma separator in
between thousands and hundreds which
which force responders to pass a parse
it as a string so we can't really
operate on these numbers and we need to
fix that in the original notebook if you
scrolled through that you would see that
there's some very complicated code that
does that replacing string coma with
with a with an empty string and applying
to numeric that is sometimes where you
can see that in in pandas read CSV
there's a there's an option for that
which would be the motor and there's an
there's an app for that because there's
an option pretty much for anything in in
read CSV called thousands so our fur
first exercise will be and we can look
up that option photo cheese
we're going to add that option to the
catalog under a section called CSV argh
so I'm going to do it for you and then
you can you can follow with more with
other options so in Jupiter I'm going to
navigate to the home folder opened the
data folder and look at the catalog as
we alluded earlier this editor opens up
this part of Jupiter it's always going
to be available for you and so I'm going
to add a new entry here which is how
intake wants me to enter every
additional parameter and this option is
called thousands and the value is just
this this column so if I save this file
and I go back
just gonna try whether this worked I'm
gonna open the catalog again and I'm
gonna read it right away
and I should see that my median house
values no parse correctly I can see
actual proper numbers in that column so
try that and follow from this point on
there are few more exercises for you
there's another issue in the near ocean
column if you scroll it it you can see
that the values are yes or no or
lowercase yes or lowercase no and for
modeling that's not very useful you
would want to parse it as ideally zero
or ones and again there's an option for
that in in pandas read CSV actually two
options that you might need to combine
so the exercise for you quickly it would
be to open the documentation of pandas
read CSV the link is right here check
out what options might apply in this
case and then try introducing them in
your catalogue reloading the catalogue
and seeing if you could if you're seeing
the right data and finally the third
exercise here is to deal with some funny
na representation in the column housing
median age for again for which again
there's a there's an option so we'll
give you just a few minutes to try this
out if you are stuck or you don't know
what this is just raise your hand and
we'll show you a sample solution in just
a few minutes
yes right yeah that's a good question
yeah yeah so I think if the if it's a
text column with commas that's fine but
if you had like another numerical column
so the question was would the thousand
separator apply to text columns I think
it would not apply to text column it
would apply to other numerical columns
yeah so what pandas does is it tries to
guess unless you provide that
information explicitly it tries to guess
what type each column is and it was
misled by those commas thinking that
this is text now you said that there
actually is a separator in my numbers
that is a coma and so now it understands
that it's a number and it will parse it
as a number but if you had another
column in which you would have some
comma separated words it would still
appear as text and it will still get
parsed as text does that make sense I
think it will try but if it sees it
still words it will keep yes go ahead oh
sorry I'll go to flip through that one
let's go yeah it's a different so
question is is there a way to set some
parameters for all data sets in a
catalog I don't think so no through this
syntax but there's something called
plugins which would let you do that so
we're going to cover that in a minute
no intake is awesome
just mention to people that there's a
gym they can just go to data and open
catalog this two questions on that
yeah
sorry
all right so we're gonna I heard some
yeas I also see some people struggling
so I'm gonna try to get everyone on the
same page by showing you a sample
solution hopefully you've been able to
achieve at least part of that again if
you want to edit these files these are
text files we're gonna use the same four
out of Python files later you can just
in your Jupiter you know click go to the
home folder that's the root of this
exercise if you open a notebook that's
the familiar interface but you can also
click on any other text file or Python
file including this catalog and edit it
right there in the built-in built-in
editor so we saw this catalog in the
data folder I should have a solution so
anytime you feel like you want to cheat
you can actually jump in there and find
all the answers the one that we're going
to look at is this catalog contains a
little bit more stuff but I'm going to
describe that in a second so the
beginning is the same we have the
metadata the sources there's just still
still this one data source it's still
CSV file I've changed the URL and to
actually instead of loading it from my
computer to load it from from github
which you can do as well and I'll put in
a variable which you can later change if
you want to load it from your github
repository so instead of a local file
you can you can just point to data sets
on the internet again catalogue that for
someone else so you found this great
link you want to share that with someone
else you attach all these other
information to it and hence it becomes a
trivial trivial example this is the
thousand separator that we talked about
this is the conversion from these to
these three lines actually or four are
the conversion from yes or knows to
zeros and once again you would find in
pandas documentation how to do that and
this is another detail that needed to be
taken care of to filter interpret none
as an n/a there are additional things
you can have in an intake catalog there
user-facing parameters so you want to
expose some flexibility to the user that
can be done through parameters here I
expose an attribute called github
username with my username as the default
but giving users the flexibility to to
change that if they so
and I'm also defining some plots
associated with the data set so if
someone gets this data set from me they
can also run some easy plots that I've
defined the parameters of to get a sense
of the data right away without having to
write a lot of coding this is optional
but but nice what it looks like together
and if I open this notebook in the
solutions folder and in quickly birth
through that for you we've just seen the
catalog if I load that one and I just do
do read you can see I'm providing this
this username I do read that's all I had
to do as a user I loaded a catalogue and
I press read I did not know where the
data was what are the parsing you know
details I don't need to know any of that
I'm just given a nice clean data frame
with all these issues taken care of
because someone else had written this
down for me and it's a standard format
that will apply to any other data set
the plotting that's just a nice feature
on top of it I can now get the housing
data set type dot plot and get get a
plot out which again has been customized
for this particularly I said so it can
be more useful to a user that sees this
for the first time questions on data
sourcing or intake we will do a quick
recap but we're going to move on to
testing right after this so if you have
questions on this part now would be the
best time
the absolute value was to pretend that
that wasn't supported built-in does it
take a lot yes so the question was what
if you have a special data source some
format that's not CSV all right
so absolutely so intake is very
extensible the technique you're looking
for is called plugins and so there is
there's the easy way of writing your own
and also online repository of plugins
that people have already written and you
can actually look at them this is the
instructions for making a driver
it's called drivers sometimes but that's
the same thing it's actually very very
simple if you used to use decoding if
you prefer to get this from like an open
source project there is a there's a
growing list of plugins that people are
written I've learned about intake last
year at this conference from from the
author and I got very excited and then
this this list has been growing ever
since so I think it's an active
community and you're likely actually
find your format here if not you or
someone can can write it put in this
repository in that anyone can use it
other questions or comments so flip back
to Stanley
all right great so um just before I give
this summary I think the first point I
wanna make is even if you didn't finish
that whole exercise it we not every
exercise doesn't really build on the
other one so you can go and try and do
that at home or just finish it or look
at the solution so all of our exercises
are independent of each other like a
well written test
so just to quickly summarize about the
use of intake so there are a few
benefits of using intakes as a key one
is you can actually just think of this
catalogue file you have now you can
actually just go and share that over the
network now someone that has the same
access as you have and they can go and
use that that your mol file we just
spoke about that catalog file just go
and load the data so that's that's a
very very big benefit of going through
all of this and like I said there is a
division between who maintains these
catalog files and who uses them so
hopefully like your data team would
provide you these catalog files as long
as you just have access yes question
so yeah who is responsible for that
you're saying or what's the question
yeah so the price price will be exactly
like the exercise almost you have to
almost go and use at your mall format
and go and write all of these and
provide the URL if it's something that
it's like a company specific you'll have
to provide like parameters like the
login details or something like that so
the process would be exactly like almost
like we try to show you the Yamal format
that's that's the process of writing it
yeah alright so and then some of the
other benefits quickly is Before we jump
into tasting sorry better is this helps
you with converting a lot of boilerplate
code into reusable catalogue files you
can use it also helps you to load a
variety of data formats into something
in a container that you are used to
working with like we mentioned pandas
dataframe a Python list or an umpire
array and then it also the catalog files
they describe data sets and this makes
it easy to reuse and you can also share
between projects and people so those are
the key some of the key benefits we want
to highlight so next we jump into
tasting so this is a very very big like
and you can actually spend this tutorial
plus a few weeks on just tasting but
we're gonna scratch the surface and show
you some some really useful things to do
and tasting but Before we jump into that
how do you know that your code normally
works as expected just think of it if
you have a problem what you normally
think is okay I need to solve this
problem this the outcome looking for
you're gonna write some code and you
just check with the code produce the
output as you would expect that's
normally how we do it but how do you and
how do you make sure that this code
actually is still valid later on once
you've done that and also we say someone
else wants to use it that's where the
challenge comes in it's immensely
challenging to make sure that your code
remains valid over a period of time and
that brings us to see firstly two
assertions and then I'll talk about
tasting a bit more so assertions in the
code help with checking certain
assumptions so in assertion is simply a
statement that checks whether something
holds true within a certain part of your
code or program and an assertion is
actually make sure that your data inputs
are valid and also your outputs are
consistent so that brings us to tasting
there are different types of testing we
mentioned three testing types here so
unit testing integration testing
integration testing so unit testing and
we're gonna look at unit testing
integration testing now an aurochs
exercises but unit testing is basically
testing a single unit of code and
checking whether that produces results
as expected and then once you combine
these pieces of code to check whether
they work correctly together that's what
we call integration takes thing and then
the last part is regression testing and
that's whether you check whether our
system behaves doesn't change its
behavior off too you can modify some of
its its details so that's that's what
you would call a regression testing and
just two more definitions I need to
provide because some of the examples
we're gonna do now will touch on this so
positive versus negative testing so a
positive test is a type of testing on a
system where you provide it with in with
valid input data so you're actually
testing whether the application behaves
as expected with positive inputs so
that's what we would define a positive
test and a negative test would then be
it's a variation of testing on a system
that just if you provide with invalid
data so it checks whether your
application behaves as expected
with negative input data and what you're
actually doing is you're checking with
their program doesn't behave like it
shouldn't behave that's why you want to
do negative testing so we can actually
jump into the exercise now I think
so again we're gonna look at some bad
practices if I just get organized here
in this notebook we've saw some code
here doing stuff that's a little bit
hard to read we can scroll a little bit
further and see more code if someone can
tell me what this does you know kudos to
you I wrote this and I still you know I
probably can't explain what it does and
he actually has bugs as well what it's
supposed to do as the comments suggest
is there's a column in the data that
contains geographic location a lot
easier longitude that turns out to be
actually very common if you attended the
keynote on Monday or is the squirrel
dataset that has the same column in it
but it has a slightly different format
if you wanted to parse it you get the
location of every squirrel in in Central
Park you would be doing something like
this but this is difficult to write it's
even more difficult to read and it has
bugs in it that are not actually at all
obvious so what we're going to do
instead is we're going to take this code
out of the notebook we're going to put
in a separate file so that we can module
our eyes it reuse it later but also that
we can test it in isolation because it
sternly said the way I would test it
here I was just running I would look at
the data I would know look at all the
data I would look at the first few lines
and our thing yeah that's okay but it's
not this may be the fourth line actually
suggests it doesn't always work but if I
was lazy I wouldn't even see that so
let's go again
to the homepage go to exercises and
we're on number three
I wrote this file for you you will find
it in the same directory it's called
parsing dog poo I just going to look at
it here but you can open it in the same
editor we use for the ML files and it
defines a Python function so I'm
assuming everyone's you know comfortable
with that I'm just gonna explain very
quickly what this does it takes one
argument the location string it uses the
split function to parse it into the four
segments the latitude string the
indicator with his north or south the
longitude string and then the indicator
whether that's East or was it done apply
some logic to convert those strings to
numbers and you use positive or negative
number if it's the northern hemisphere
or the eastern etc which is how these
coordinates are defined and is then
returns these two numbers the latitude
and the longitude what it's supposed to
do if I then import it back into my
notebook
so from parsing this is the parsing file
I'll import parse location I run it on a
string it doesn't actually work right
because there's some bugs and I should
kind of I could squint at the code for
some time and maybe you already see some
issues but a better way is to actually
write a test that will do this testing
for me and that I can later automate so
we're gonna before we fix this issue
we're gonna look at one more file in the
same directory called test parsing the
file is going to do the same as I did it
will import the parse location and it
defines the special function called test
location which we refer to as unit test
this function there's only one thing it
runs an assert which is a special
expression in Python which will do
nothing if the expression is correct if
it's true but it will fail and it will
give me an error if it's not true so I'm
going to assert that the parse location
is what I would expect it to be in this
case three four five six and one two
three four five and then we're going to
you know use this tool called PI test
that some people have raised their hands
they're familiar with already to
automate this testing what it looks like
is on a command line in terminal or with
an exclamation mark you know
Python in Jupiter I can run PI test test
parsing and what I should see is an
output that will look like this it will
have some header that we can skip for
now that it will say it found one test
in the test parsing its following this
naming convention everything that begins
with the word test will be will be
executed and it tells me F it failed
depending on what console you're running
you might get colored output you know it
would be red and it tells me no one
which I got is not equal to 35 56 that I
was expecting there's a problem fix it
so the exercise now for you is to go
back to the code in the parsing file see
if you can spot that if you if you can
fix it and rerun this test and whether
you can you can make it happy so the way
you can do it is to navigate to this
exercise folder and open the parsing
file see if you can see some bugs fix
them you can go back to your notebook or
terminal or rerun the test until it's
happy we'll give it a minute or two and
then we can get around the same page
again
so again if you're not sure completely
what to do just put up your hand and try
help
so in the interest of time I'm just
gonna ask if anyone found a bug - bugs
where's the first one yes so this is one
bug right and the other bug
that's correct there's an operator
precedence issue because the way python
interprets this is different from how we
you would actually read it you want to
multiply it by the whole expression not
just a minus one there's actually a
third back I don't know if anyone can
see it so there's a back here this is
minus one in both sides you only get it
if you actually test with both north
east and west which you know the data
would actually not have because it's
California right that's how you would
not know so this is fixing the code but
we also need to improve our tests
because working with just one sample is
not enough you found some bugs but not
necessary all I'm gonna jump now to the
solutions and show you a little bit more
so I improved the function a little bit
I'm just going to comment on some of
those points where they are not critical
right now I actually went back to using
a regular expression which may not be a
good idea but for the if I have good
tests then I can be more comfortable
about my code then if I don't have those
tests and I would probably not venture
into that space I've also added a little
bit more comments I've explained what
the function does also what you can
raise if the invalid if the location is
actually invalid this is the negative
test cases that we want to understand
and I've added a few examples this is
useful for anyone that wants to use that
function or for me later to understand
how to use it and what to get what to
expect why I'm showing it here because I
can get double value from doing this
this can also be tested turns out that
PI tests can also see these types of
comments and validate that they're
actually true in my function and we
don't have to go through that code very
much I just rewrote that logic a little
bit but I also added a error message
that will be raised if the location is
not valid and I will write tests to make
sure that that does happen in the cases
where I would expect it you may have if
you had the time which you probably
didn't because we're running this pretty
quickly you could have tried different
locations in PI test if you want to save
yourself some typing there is a tool
called promote rise where you can
extract these different test cases into
like a little list and then just repeat
the same instead of writing these lines
10 times you repeat them basically you
could imagine this is like a slightly
better for loop
I'm just enumerating these test cases
but I'm trying like the north and south
pole and then different different
combinations and just making sure that
it will always work I then also define
these negative test cases so how about
you know strings that are just not
correct will the function return
something or will it raise the correct
expected exception and for that I'm
using this high test raises tool that
that is part of PI test so this was the
test file if I run that again hopefully
this will not work it found these many
tests hdall is a test and I have now
good outcome from high-test telling me
that 12th module 12 tests passed I have
confidence in my code I can share it and
someone using this code can trust that
it actually will work if you've been to
tutorials I've heard it multiple times
people say I'll bring this I created
this open-source package it has 100%
code coverage and it's you know claim to
fame then because claim to fame you can
claim that all your cold
Oriol lines of code actually have tests
written for them so people can trust
your package and people use this to
advertise their the code quality of
their products the one thing I wanted to
highlight at the very end is this option
to PI test that if you add it will
actually run these examples from your
documentation as tests and it will
verify whether that's true or not that's
very useful if you do use if you write
documentation for others you put
examples there you wanna make sure those
examples are correct well this this tool
will verify that for you so if I run
this again it will actually find one
additional test in the parsing file know
that this is not the test parsing is the
actual source code a file and it
verified that as well questions for
testing we're going to go to do a quick
recap and we're going to move on to code
quality and then performance if your
question on testing on using PI tests or
in general please ask
confusing so how large or small is so
the question is you know what does units
in the world unit test actually refer to
and I think it you know people would
probably give you very different answers
I think the rule of thumb is that it
should match to like one function or
like one aspect of functionality right
if it's easier to test things one at a
time rather than test some very large
complicated workflow in which many
things can go wrong
your test will be simpler if the test if
the thing you're testing is simple here
we're just testing you know simple input
simple output so a unit typically means
a single function or a single operation
right
okay so unit would be that for loop but
you would write multiple test cases to
explore the different code paths that
you can get into or different test cases
right so like in here I you you would
write inputs that explore the different
situations your code can get into so
that all that part is all that code is
exercise that's how you achieve that
hundred percent code coverage you
actually create situations in which all
parts of the code get executed
all right just a quick recap thing on
tasting so firstly the we we mentioned
this a few times but taste driven code
does build trust
like preparer also mentioned when people
write packages actually do you say full
coverage or not so that Bulls trust it
also maintains validity of code over
time so as people start making changes
to your code base they can just read on
the tests and make sure that everything
is still valid and in also testing
encourages programmers to better design
their programs as well and also derived
in testable manner and what that means
is you create self contained almost
functions and classes that can more or
less run independently of one another
and that actually helps this way this
way of designing code and this way of
looking at code helps your code to be
more understandable and reusable so
that's the the quick summary of testing
and also there was a talk today just
before lunch at PI data in New York by
Raul about it was more advanced testing
but he actually covered all of these
aspects he also looked at he also looked
at doc test hypothesis which will
hopefully look at later on and PI taste
so I think if you have if you have if
you didn't attain that talk maybe look
that up later on and let guys into a bit
more advanced testing so let's go to the
next port so now we get we jump to code
quality so how did it just ask yourself
the question how does one improve code
quality so the answer would be by
modularizing reusing and also by making
code more readable so firstly when you
when you say i'm modularizing what do we
mean by that that means when you write
like short single purpose functions with
very very well and defined inputs and
outputs so um you should always modular
ice codes rather than copying pasting
code so if you see a piece of code where
you repeat the same thing a few times
like a few even if statements but or a
few things do repeat you know it you're
not yorker quality is not up to standard
so you want to try and modularize that
modularizing code allows others to
understand or to to remember its
functionality in a single main middle
chunk so what that means is people
can actually go and understand the
functionality of this function and that
helps with also with understand ability
of code and this also a side effect of
modularizing code is it leads to more
readable read reusable and testable code
as well and you should always decompose
your programs into functions and then a
rule of thumb is not to have too many
input parameters I think a real thumb
would be to have five to six input
parameters and also don't don't turn
reference outside information your
functions and the main motivation for
this is you want your your functions
everything to fit into the most limited
memory short-term memory of all and
that's the human memory short-term
memory so you want to try and keep it
into small pieces if you see this code
like it's hundreds of lines of code and
trying to solve something it's very very
difficult to follow through or to follow
um you should always reuse code instead
of trying to rewrite it there's a lot of
well-defined problems out there that
people have solved with very very well
unwritten libraries and packages so
probably is that in trying to solve or
write your own routine to solve problems
and also as you see actually some of the
functions as better right you should
always explain your function with a doc
string or so that explains it in words
what what you're trying to do and
achieve here then the second last point
will be you should always give your
functions and variables well-defined and
meaningful names that helps to document
the purpose of your of your functions
and also it makes your code more
readable and all of what I've said now
is actually quite subjective you could
go into a debate of hey my code is my
quality is quite good you have to indent
like three or four times and you have to
do your commentary this way or so so
forth so we do encourage you to use
tools to evaluate and ultimately check
for known issues and then to try and
have this debate will also save you
quite a bit of time so we can actually
now jump into an exercise with a belief
will use pilant to try and check our
quality
so yes any said this tutorial is mostly
about tools right and you could debate
endlessly which code is better and
everyone thinks their code is the best
so there actually there are luckily
tools that can bring some objectivity to
this and also automation to highlight
and find some of these issues so I'm
gonna jump out of presentation and as
you can guess by now we're gonna use the
number for exercise so Jupiter exercise
this number for this one is short as
we're just gonna do it together I'm
gonna walk you through that this blob of
text is basically what we just concluded
and leads to this introduction of a tool
called Pyland there are many similar
tools this is one of the best though
that similar to pi tests can look at
your code but instead of running it it
will scan through that code and
highlight some of issues that it thinks
exist in your code and and these are
defined as rules in that so I'm gonna
try doing this on this parsing function
that we just used and let's see what
comes out so I'm going to say
exclamation pile int parsing doc py and
it gives me an output it looks like this
it gives me a filename and the line so
in line 8 the character if that matters
and then it complains about some things
so it's actually very pedantic it
complains even about extra spaces at the
ends of lines that's maybe not that
useful but it also can complain about
missing module doc string so a stand
aside is good to document where your
modules and functions are for if you
don't do that this tool can highlight
that it tells me that I'm not using the
variable longitude which actually was
one of the bugs I was accidentally using
the longitude string not the longitude
and this tool would have told me if I
looked at it it's also telling me that I
have an import OS that I'm not using so
this code was pretty short but it still
highlighted some issues if I don't want
to deal with trailing whitespace errors
I can disable them either in the coder
on the command line using a parameter -
- disabled
and we run again now I'm getting a
slightly more useful output I'm also
getting a score at the end so these are
all metrics you can apply to your code
base and watch overtime to see how
you're doing if you write a lot of
functions you can pay attention to this
and see if the quality is looking
overall deteriorating and and what are
the issues there are also different
classes of issues see for convention w-4
warning for really serious problems you
would have an error so in the interest
of time before they fix those issues so
we're going to jump through the last
exercise which is to look at some really
bad calls I'm just going to put it on
the screen for a minute and just look at
it and count for yourself what issues
you would highlight on this code if a
colleague of yours gave it to you to run
without further explanation would you
understand what the code does would you
see any bugs and and or what do you know
what it's for I can actually see there's
a there's a typo here so I'm just going
to fix it real quick wondering how we
got it
so this does not does not need to be
reflected upon very long you know the
code is not very meaningful it's not
very clear what it does and it seems to
be not quite logical anyway in there
there's some bugs in it but just in your
in your own head see if you can spot
some we're gonna compare that to the
output of Pyland to see what it would
tell us so I'm just gonna run it on this
bed code and see if it's useful so it's
complaining that we don't have a doc
string it's also complaining about the
veining right it's like a popular name
if you don't know how to name something
in programming you name it fool but it
doesn't really help there's the same
people naming data frames DF how do you
know what's in it right just by the name
so it has a list a black list of names
that it looks for and if you use them it
will complain it has some more pedantic
conventions about argument names also UV
may not necessarily be the best name
there's a missing doc string it's
telling me that I don't need to have an
else--if if I'm returning again that's
an option you know that's an optional
thing you can turn off if you don't like
but more important is complaining about
the fact that I'm not being consistent
in that function I'm in one branch
returning in the other one just printing
something that the function doesn't
really behave in any consistent
inconsistent way and finally there's an
error which is highlighting a bug in the
code it says too many positional
arguments for function call if you look
at the line 15 that's this line or I'm
calling the function foo with three
arguments it's defined with two right so
this will actually break and without
running the code pile in the smart
enough to tell me that so it understands
your called
it has some predefined patterns that it
looks forward and it's generally a
useful tool to have to validate your
code on top of the tests that you should
that you should write and I got a score
of minus 11 out of 10 so congratulations
to me see if you can do better
that is cool quality I'm gonna do a
quick recap and move to the last section
we're doing ok on time but if anyone has
questions now would be a good time to
ask
yeah
all right quickly on a on the recap
actually just it's not too much to recap
but here but they are if you want to go
and look at this I think you would it
would be useful to go and actually look
at a pilot and also use the options that
Peter mentioned to disable some of the
information you'll get and then also
we've provided some links to other types
of tools that might be very useful to
use under the see also section so let's
let's jump over to performance now so
with performance and I think this is
very very useful to especially if you
struggling with a bit of performance the
first golden rule firstly is before you
actually try and optimize your code for
performance you should always make sure
it works sourced right so that's the
first thing otherwise would be quite
frustrating to try and optimize
performance so the most productive way
to make your code fast is first to check
whether it it does as expected and then
the next question you should ask
yourself is is it actually worth
spending the time to optimize my code
and then once you've determined yes it
is I want to optimize my code you should
use tools like profiler or line profiler
to determine where your code is actually
spending time and and in terms of that
also what area might be worth optimizing
once you've determined that which will
show you how to do then you can actually
go and use some of the pre pre bolt like
I mentioned earlier as well pre-built
functions is out there or packages is
out there it's already optimized for
performance like numpy pandas and slide
by to try and see if you can you can
make a code faster once you've done that
then okay so let's take a the last one
would actually do also to when you do
any operations on rows that's actually
not a good thing is you're trying all
these operations across columns which
will speed up your your code and then
the last one would be once you've done
all of this you've tried to optimize the
code itself then you can use something
like number to compile curtain hotspots
so we're going to show you all of these
now using profiler are to identify
bottlenecks then make some changes using
these bolting methods and then at the
end of the day just show you also how we
can use number so this is the last
exercise and also maybe the most complex
so whenever you get stuck please raise
your hand someone will stop by or ask
your questions right away and we'll
address it directly we're going to use
actually multip
tools now but hopefully it will still
make sense so before I jump to the
notebooks I'm just gonna illustrate
where we're coming from to give you a
little bit of the background in in the
sample notebook if you continue with
this workflow we've parsed some data we
look to date we decided that we want to
build a model so we built we prepare the
data nothing spectacular going on there
we create some additional features we
put in a Const column we train a linear
model on this it's obviously very bad
model don't do this don't use it we look
at its resolve but reason I'm going
through this is then we get to some
custom code I've written a function here
that evaluates the root mean square
error as a way of measuring the
performance and I didn't listen to Stan
Lee so I did it row by row which is
going to be very slow I didn't use any
optimization on a small data set it may
not matter which which is then okay but
on a large data set this could actually
be a Productivity killer and so we want
to see if we can do better with this
code right it calculates the our MSE but
otherwise other than that it's not a
very performant code and we'll get in a
second into why that is I have some
additional code here that we can guest
you in an optional exercise but first
let's together jump into the exercises
so 0-5 performance and I'm gonna preload
one additional thing line profiler I'm
gonna get to what that means later on
but that's just for the set up as a
recap this is the definition again it's
obligatory to put a math formula on the
slides should give it you know and
that's sure that we're legit this is
this is it there's not much more than
that yeah they take of course you can
see that we're we're advanced yeah this
is the function and I'm just gonna
measure how it runs all right and and
this is kind of the sequence in which
you would typically go here we don't
care about the numbers I'm just going to
generate some random
data so that I can measure the
performance in something sizable I'm
gonna have a million random numbers in
in two different columns one would be in
this case the predicted the other one
would be the actual but it doesn't
really matter what I'm interested is the
time not the not the answer so there's
there's a magic command interpreter
called percent time if I put it in front
of any expression it's gonna measure the
time it takes to execute that line
there's a multi-line version percent
percent time that you would use and
larger to measure larger blocks so
everyone will now get a slightly
different number on my computer actually
system this computer it took 1.4 seconds
issue you should see something in that
order alright and now I have to make the
first choice is this too much is this
too little does this matter if it's one
point for a second and I'm just gonna
run it once it doesn't matter but if
it's something that gets called very
often or it came out as 15 minutes then
I want to probably continue however it's
not always that accurate if I do it
again I'm gonna get a slightly different
answer because things in computer is
fluctuate a little bit sometimes the
first time you're on something it faster
or slower so there's another one which
is slightly better it's called time 8
what is going to do is going to run your
code multiple times and then give you
the average so if you're not tying some
code is actually a better version and it
takes a little bit longer because it's
running it multiple times but it's going
to give me an overall statistic about
the code so here I'm looking at one
point three six seconds plus or minus 85
milliseconds I have a better idea
about that code so let's say I've
determined that this is too much I need
this code to go faster because it's in
some critical portion of my code base so
how can I figure out what's wrong with
it
there are two tools that we're going to
look at they're called profilers and
they are going to measure word the time
is actually being spent this 1.3 seconds
where is that going so the first one is
a built-in profiler it comes with Python
and it has a magical Piron for profiler
run which I'm going to do in this
function and I'm gonna get an output
that breaks it down by function in this
case it's not super useful if I squinted
it I can kind of see that there is this
square root that's with a bunch of zero
so it's not actually taking much time I
can see my RMS C function here taking
most of the time in code where lots of
functions are involved this will be more
useful in this case we're not really
getting much insights from this alone so
we're going to use another tool the so
called line profiler and as you can
guess from the name it's going to give
me a line by line information so if I do
that again it's gonna run my code again
but it's going to trace per line where
the time is being spent and now you can
have your code on the right-hand side
and the timing on the left and it gives
you much better idea so you can see that
78% or this many this many I guess
milliseconds are spent on this line 21
percent on the iteration so most of the
work is actually on this line 21 percent
here and so if I were to optimize this
is how I would go about it this would be
the focal points of my optimization so
how can we optimize operating on lots of
data in Python is typically slow if you
do it on line by line basis so what you
want to do is to leverage libraries that
can do it faster so the first thing I
would reach for is to use numpy since
I'm already having the data in that
format and as you probably all know
numpy has you know the standard math
operations that I was doing on
individual values defined also for
vectors so I can actually do the minus
and the square on the entire array I can
sum it and divide it and then return the
Square mean so I can define this
function which does the same thing and I
can time it again and now let's see if
that helped so I'm using time it again
to run a couple times and hopefully I'm
now looking at 10 milliseconds and if
you remember that's actually a very good
improvement because we were at 1.3
seconds before so this is a great
improvement it's typically a kind of
orders of magnitude improvement if the
original code was really bad
I can look at the timing again using the
line profiler I can see that most of the
time is now being spent in this
expression and there's some time being
spent in the mean so I could continue
this and see if there are faster ways
for these expressions and one way to do
that is to use code compilation so you
may have heard everyone here uses Python
but there are other languages we're not
supposed to talk about them in this
conference but they have some advantages
and some of them are faster languages
like C C++ or Java are faster and
they're faster for reason that they're
compiled that means they're actually
translated into machine code and then
computer runs then they they execute
much faster we can reap some of those
benefits in Python still with tools like
number which lets us compile parts of
the Python code which otherwise is not
compiled into machine instructions the
way you could do that is to add this
magic almost decorator to the function
so the function is exactly the same as
before but I'm I'm adding this ng at
number and G decorator to it ng it
stands for just-in-time compilation
which means it's going to get compiled
the first time I'm going to use it and n
stands for no Python which I'm going to
recommend is the default there actually
is a JIT decorator as well which is what
you will most commonly find in the
documentation but it has this tricky
behavior that if you put something in
the code that number cannot compile it
will default to just running Python and
will necessarily tell you and it will
just be very slow and you will not know
why so people use JIT with an option
called no Python Oh apologies
life coating yeah but if you get put you
know if you don't want to type this all
the time you can just do n j-- it which
is which is the same so what this is
going to do it's going to take this
function and compile it the first time i
run it so if i want to try it now
i'm gonna use the time so that it runs
only ones and actually you know it
wasn't terribly slow but it's not what
I'm looking for here but the next time
I'm gonna call it and I'm gonna use time
it for that it should be much faster so
let's look at that so now I'm at five
point nine six milliseconds so let's
compare that to this version that was
ten so I've got the run time even
further down by compiling the code that
was previously already fast should we do
it everywhere should we use number for
everything well it turns out we can't
it's only a subset of Python that can
work this way most of just regular
Python code will work most of numpy
operations will work but for example
operations on pandas dataframes well
will not work there's a project by intel
called SDC previously each part that
focuses on that that is covering pandas
the same way but if you're operating on
numpy eraser just using regular Python
operations that this can make a terrible
this can make a big difference but I'm
also losing certain things because the
code is not compiled I cannot use some
of the benefits and flexibility that
Python gives for example I can no longer
use the line profiler because python
does no longer see line by line
execution these are machine instructions
that are a little bit cryptic to do
anyone who's to look at it also things
like debugger would not work in this
case and I can compare this against code
that someone else wrote and an optimized
so in the stats models library there's a
rms implementation can time that and
let's see how we did that compares to
that implementation and ten ten
milliseconds so it's not the best time
the best was actually this compiled but
it's probably still my bad
choice because this is a function that
someone else wrote so I don't have to
write that code it would have tests it
would have much better documentation and
it probably will cover some edge cases
that I haven't thought about which my
naive you know few line implementation
here would not process correctly so
after all this I would probably conclude
that actually my best bet is to use this
function that someone else wrote about
at least I know that it's relatively
optimal and we have about five minutes
left so I'll flip back to Stanley and to
bring us to the conclusion and if you
have any questions please far away and
we can stay around a little longer as
well
yeah so I think actually if you go and
look at the github repository we
actually have property based tasting as
well I think there's analytics exercise
on that I would encourage you to go and
look at that too but just to quickly
summarize what we've just discussed here
so for performance like we mentioned you
should always make sure whether your
code works first before you try and
optimize performance you can use magics
like time and time it to go and
determine how long it runs then you can
use profiler to see where we are with
the the bottlenecks and then you should
use optimized and methods that you
what's out there to try and optimize
your code and then only use things like
number to try and solve your or to make
your code more optimal so we've also
provided some good links there as you
can go and look at some talks and
tutorials to dig in deeper so we
actually want to conclude this bring
everything together quickly and it's
like four key things that I would want
you to read to walk away with we've said
a lot of things but the first thing is
and that's a bit controversial well I do
believe in this and we believe in this a
lot is you have to write programs for
people not computers and the reason for
that is if you want your code to be used
people need to understand it and a lot
of what we mention reproducibility code
quality and putting comments in your
code doing making tastes all of that
provides trust and also people with and
start using that right the the second
point would be make it readable or
reusable and testable like you could
just look at all of those three
components and then optimize only after
you found that something works and then
the last thing would be obviously and
that's actually collaborating and
sharing knowledge helps with improving
your code if you have more people
working on your projects more people
more eyes looking at the code itself the
better it's gonna be so that'll be the
how we conclude and if there's any
questions please let us know so yeah we
will open for questions and I think we
have about three minutes for questions
if there are any
you definitely strive for 100% code
coverage because I always have the
trade-off between so the question is
should you strive for a hundred percent
code coverage and it's actually a little
bit of a controversial topic hundred
percent turns out to be actually a
misleading kind of a false target you
can have hundred percent coverage and
still have a lot of bugs and code in
your code so what you should strive for
I think is kind of a non decreasing
trend in your code coverage so when
you're adding code you're also adding
the tests but rather than aiming for a
hundred percent I think it's better to
spend that time in deploying other tools
that can check other aspects of the code
such as piling the checks the quality
and the naming and the readability but
also things that actually make your
tests more powerful like hypothesis
unfortunately we didn't have time to dig
into that but our repo has that exercise
you can look into solutions it would be
number six it has a brief explanation
and a demo you can run hypotheses in
just a few sentences would be a tool you
can use to generate the various use
cases you remember in in our example we
have to enumerate these different
latitude and longitude combinations
hypothesis lets you actually is kind of
your your test engineer that generates
these for you based on some predefined
specifications so you would say what
kind of numbers you're going to work
with and what what assumptions you're
making about the results and it will
generate you a ton of use case in and
explore all the coroner cases that you
would not think of and that's much more
valuable than a hundred percent cold
coverage because it's actually in-depth
testing of you know all the dark corners
of of your code that would not come out
otherwise it was another question
story
so one issue that I constantly run into
when rules
is trying to follow the logic of the
flow
I don't know if you guys have any best
practice recommendations
like the structuring insurance of like
the logical flow
you know cold you're running or
the finest level or
yeah I think I think this is hard so the
question was how do you structure your
call it how do you keep it
understandable in terms of what the
workflow looks like and you're not alone
there there is um this is major topic
that everyone struggles with if there is
it's also very good xkcd comic on how do
you understand other people's code
there's this bizarre you know places the
person gets to that has no unjust no
understanding what they mean and I think
there's always going to be a challenge
but you can simplify things by breaking
things down into logical modular units
right so we've just used a few files
here but in a larger project you would
have more similar parsing tools you
would have some testing tools you want
to organize them by topic you know make
sure that the contracts that these
things are declare in terms of inputs
and what they do are are meaningful that
they're documentation and kind of
decompose things into into chunks that
are small enough to be understandable
anything that's going to be large and
complex will always gonna be difficult
so just breaking things down into
hierarchies and reusing things is what
we what we try to do there were some
tutorials on packaging so rather than
having on one big blob of code and
repository of everything packaging
things into smaller components is an
answer and there are techniques in
Python that we did not explore here but
that lets you lets you do that and I
think you can see that in the open
source ecosystem you can pulling these
single or multiple use tools together
effectively imagine just having to write
all that yourself
yes yes so there is there's a tool
there's a tool for generating
documentation called Sphinx SP a INX
what that would do is would look at your
code and you remember we had these dog
strings at the beginning of the function
remodel it would extract those and
generate like a readable documentation
from that plus any text you write on top
of it any open source project that you
would have seen on this conference
pretty much uses that to generate the
documentation if you go to you know read
the docs for pandas or whatever you will
find documentation that was generated
that way and one of the plugins to that
tool is a module dependency so it
virtually generates what you just said a
graph of module to module dependencies
so you can see what depends on Walt and
if it gets very complex that's the time
to refactor
yes the question is if you use numba
does it prevent debugging and if so can
you manage that by having like a version
for debugging version for production so
short answer yes it does prevent
debugging it compiles it to an Elder VM
representation which which you can't
inspect in Python there are probably
some tools you can use still but they're
much more low-level that would not be in
Python debugger anymore but since it's
just a Python decorator you can you can
use it flexible you can turn it off
programmatically based on options right
that's kind of up to you but it's
certain it can be an option you
introduced in your code base I'm not
aware of some kind of a global switch
for that but it's it since it's just
Python code on top of your function you
can do whatever you want with it
all right this is the last question
I can't figure out how it's organized
like whether functions that I just call
the same thing or move together or maybe
there's a main function at the bottom so
and then I'm trying to see all right yes
the question is you you're trying to
contribute an open-source project but
you can't really find your way around
you don't know how the code works and
and there may be no tests also so you
you should tell the author to watch our
tutorial because I think as the
maintainer of that package right I would
want to see tests for your change right
first at all the existing tests work and
then any new test that you written also
work answer well so you probably want to
walk away and contribute a different
open-source package or write write the
test all right I think I think we have
to wrap up thank you very much I hope
you enjoy this
[Applause]